pre-fire is directed by ben wheatley and
stars in all-star casts of people who
really enjoy saying the f-word and it's
about some arms dealers and some arms
buyers who are meeting at a deserted
warehouse and things go wrong there's a
problem between a few of them tension
runs high and all of a sudden they're
all shooting at each other can they all
make it out alive now when I first saw
the trailer for this film I was
expecting it to be a fun action film
that had doses of fun but was more
focused on action having seen it this is
almost like a slapstick comedy it's not
full comedy it's not like it's you know
Leslie Nielsen or mr. bean or something
it's just there's quite a lot more
equipping and a lot more fun to be had
in this movie than I expected in some
ways that's a detriment to this film and
in some ways it's actually quite
enjoyable the first half of the movie I
liked quite a bit I love this set up for
these characters I thought Killian
Murphy was really great and probably the
character that I was most interested in
and that's largely because the majority
of them don't have much development to
be given to them which isn't really
necessarily a huge problem because this
film on paper is essentially just a
concept that is being stretched to its
extremes in regards to feature-length
runtimes there are large portions of
this movie that I enjoyed and most of it
has to do with the cast themselves not
so much the dialog they were given to
say but the fact that the cast is so
talented they're able to find just the
right levels that their characters
should be at unfortunately the movie is
in great and a lot of it did have to do
with the way the film was directed
Wheatley makes the choice to film pretty
much the entire film handheld a lot of
it does feel very shaky not like Paul
Greengrass shaky but there are times
where you honestly can't tell who's
firing it who it's a lot of people
turning around a corner firing the
ducking for cover and you cut back to a
bullet ricocheting off something and
you're not exactly sure what's going on
also I think my biggest issue with the
movie is the setup for why they all get
into this shootout basically two people
there kind of have a thing and it's a
problem and I feel like in real life
everyone there we've just been like hey
you guys go over there in the corner and
figure this shit out and we're just
going to wait but instead everybody just
draws their
weapons and starts firing like no one
gives a shit anymore about living which
is very strange to me and that's where
the comedy edge comes in with this movie
you can tell that they were thinking
that it's just a fun movie where shit
gets real but we're going to make a lot
of jokes and we're going to have really
over-the-top sound effects a lot of bang
wiz and zoom sound effects to kind of
make you feel like you're watching
something that's more silly and
light-hearted but the setup wasn't it
was almost like it was setting up more
of a reservoir dogs' type feel where
you're in one main location there's a
lot of jokes and humor but in the end it
is a serious dramatic picture as far as
the performances I would say that
sharlto copley was incredible in this
movie I found him extremely hilarious
sometimes you couldn't quite understand
what he was saying but it just added to
the comedy more for me also as I said
Killian Murphy was really great I was
disappointed I got to be honest in brie
Larson I didn't really think that she
was in the same movie it felt like her
character was in a different movie for
the large portion of this movie most
everyone after the halfway point is just
crawling around trying to find a weapon
or trying to get to something and it
does drag after a while it's kind of
like okay you know I can't really tell
who's firing at who and these arms
dealers and arms buyers have aim worse
than stormtroopers so there's that too
and it just doesn't really feel like the
movie knew what it was the cast alone
elevates this material to be
entertaining enough to watch but the
motivation for why everybody starts
shooting at each other was so weak that
I couldn't really get invested in the
movie and I kept thinking okay they set
up one character as the really dumb guy
who does really dumb things but you're
all kind of dumb like are somebody needs
to just wave the white flag and you guys
could all go home but it kind of felt
like the screenplay just wanted them to
all be there and just kill each other
but like I said it's entertaining enough
to watch perhaps as a rental once the
blu-ray comes out check it out maybe on
Amazon in the future I'm going to give
free fire a C+ so guys I'm going to have
a lot of reviews this weekend I'm going
to see that Katherine Heigl rosario
Dawson movie unforgettable tomorrow if
that's amazing enough to want to review
in the way that I expect it to be I'll
be doing a video of that I also want to
check out the movie scene
forgotten which kind of looks like a
Blair Witch Project alien version but
I'll watch it oh and also um my
shoulders kind of hurtin like I feel
like maybe I don't know like maybe I got
a tattoo or something but maybe that's
why I haven't wanted to get a tattoo for
a really long time
and it took me quite a bit to find the
right artist and that was really the big
thing was like okay I need to find the
right artist so I finally did this is
the crop circle in the movie signs as my
longtime viewers know and I've heard me
say many times over and over again signs
is the movie I saw that made me want to
pursue a career in film and I got to
give a humongous thank you to Bethany
Hendricks who works at collective
tattoos in Stowe Ohio she did a
phenomenal job and in the future I want
to get more I kind of want to turn my
whole right arm into a sleeve get
various movies that I think are just
badass
I have a lot of ideas and I've always
kind of wanted tattoos it was just like
find the right artist find the right
time so yeah if you're looking to get
inked check out collective tattoos this
is not sponsored by them they have no
idea I'm doing this I don't even think
Bethany knows I told her I would say
that she did a good job and if you're
watching this Bethany you were amazing
and I can't wait to get more guys thank
you so much as always for watching and
if you'd like this you can click right
here and get steppen eyes
[Music]